think we've seen over the last year in
particular the impact that happens to
people's bills at home when energy
policy doesn't work properly when we're
relying on imported energy from hostile
countries that's why the creation today
of a new Department focused specifically
on energy security and Net Zero is so
important it's going to mean that we can
reduce People's Energy bills that's so
important it means we can produce more
energy here at home giving us
independence and security and it means
we can transition to cleaner forms of
energy as we hit our Net Zero Ambitions
and create jobs in the process as we're
seeing here today that's why today's
changes are really important we're
focused on delivering for the British
people and this will help us do that